PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Today, we're talking
about zero trust, VPC service
controls, and a podcast
about the blog.
I am Priyanka.
And welcome to "This
Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
We believe zero trust
is an effective way
to enhance overall security
and provide a better user
experience.
And BeyondCorp Enterprise
can help make this possible.
That's why we are excited to
announce three new BeyondCorp
Enterprise features designed
to help our customers provide
their users simple and secure
access to key applications--
certificate-based access
via VPC Service Controls,
on-prem connector, and easy
to configure custom access
policies.
Google Cloud strives to be
the most trusted cloud, which
is why we are continuously
updating our protection
capabilities.
In addition to IAP, we now
support VPC Service Controls
for Cloud Run, which creates
enterprise-grade security
guardrails protecting your
data at the network level
while delivering the ease
of use and speed to market.
The Google Cloud tech
blog is a great resource
for all things happening
in Google Cloud.
And if you prefer to listen
rather than read, check out
the "Google Cloud Reader"
podcast, available wherever
you listen to
podcasts, and enjoy
an audio version of the latest
and greatest with Google Cloud.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.